new male artist of the year jimmy allen
travis denning hardy cody johnson
parker mccullum new female artist of the
year
ingrid andres teneal arts gabby barrett
mickey guyton kaylee hammock album of
the year
born here live here die here luke ryan
mixtape volume one
kane brown never will ashley mcbride
skeletons brothers osborne starting over
chris stapleton song of the year
blue bird miranda lambert one night
standards
ashley mcbride some people do old
dominion
starting over chris stapleton the bones
marin morris video of the year
better than we found it marin morris
blue bert
miranda lambert gone dirk's bentley
hallelujah carrie underwood and john
legend
worldwide beautiful kane brown
music event of the year be light thomas
rhett
featuring reba mcintyre hilary scott
chris tomlin
keith irvin does to me luke combs
featuring eric church i hope you're
happy now
carly pierce and lee rice nobody but you
blake shelton featuring gwen stefani
one beer hardy featuring lauren elena
and devin dawson
one too many keith urban and peek
you